hello no Danny can't come to the phone
right now why cuz he's dead just kidding
that joke Danny is alive just not here
please keep watching because we've got
an update from Rihanna about that Lupita
Nyong'o heist movie that Twitter
invented some exclusive a Big Brother
scoop and of course it is new music
Friday hi friends obviously I am NOT
Danny direct oh I embrace sander taking
over the daily Deni Walt any much
deserved it day off Wow
Frank every time I say Denny anyway
think of Denny as Kelly Ripa and me is
like Busy Philipps stepping in to do
life or a day
taller but different and still fun so
let's just jump right in shall we
first up we've got Rihanna taking a New
York Fashion Week by storm at the launch
of her fenty beauty line et was the
first on the red carpet last night
chatting with Queen RiRi about
everything from body positivity to that
movie we are all dying to see you are
one of the most beautiful women in the
entire world when you look in the mirror
do you see that beauty do you ever feel
insecure oh I'm very realistic when I
look in the mirror like I know if I'm in
shape out of shape if I gots it's about
dark circles I'm not like lying to
myself and I'm not feeling bad about
that either
this line you said it's very important
to you to create beauty for all women
why is that beer manifesto because all
women deserve to feel beautiful and all
women deserve to have a choice and an
option when they go to the makeup
counter I don't think that's fair to
limit it to one
shade or one coupe shade you know I have
friends of all races all skin tones and
I think it's painful to exclude anyone
women love makeup and they should all be
included you really are at work work
work work working all around the world
with two movies coming out and you're
working with Ava Duvernay and Lupita
next this is incredible tell me about
your role and this is a it's still in
the very very early stages I hope that
we can really pull this off because the
fans kind of created this momentum and
this idea and we really want to make
them happy it better happen Rihanna okay
moving on it to Taylor Swift she's kept
pretty quiet since she started rolling
out all things reputation but her music
video director Joseph Kahn not so much
remember when the look what you made me
do vid dropped and people started
calling out Tay for copying Beyonce's
formation
[Music]
well Joseph is clapping back and telling
those haters that Queen Bee copied
Taylor yes the director tells the LA
Times quote they try to say she's
wearing a black crop top and Beyonce
wore a black crop top but they don't
realize in 2015 in bad blood Taylor
Swift was wearing a black crop top I
really do think by the way that beyonce
copied bad blood and I saw Cady heron
wearing army pants and flip-flops so I
bought army pants and flip-flops come on
people let's keep it real neither
Beyonce nor Taylor invented crop tops or
standing in formation let them live to
be fair Joseph went on to tweet that he
was maybe just trolling us with those
comments so who knows what I do know for
sure is that this announcement from last
night's big brother is a hundred percent
real this winter for the first time ever
the unexpected is coming Celebrity Big
Brother full of celebrities locked up
behind those doors
can you imagine it you'll learn all
about it soon enough finally so that is
coming this winter like Julie said and
then next summer
it's bigger brothers 20th season and a
lot of people want it to be an all-stars
version cuz there hasn't been one of
those since 2006 I was actually with
some former BB houseguests not too long
ago and they all weighed in on coming
back check this out Definitely Maybe no
one else you're gonna have that kind of
shot at a half a million dollars do you
want to come back and play absolutely
absolutely I mean it I have now lost
eight reality TV competitions I would
always play yeah I would all I would
never turn Big Brother down you know
it's fine I would love for it to be an
all-star season I just played an
all-star on Survivor completely
different world
completely different I was like wow like
I'm playing with the big fish who would
you like to see
come back and play again I think you
have a wide range of players you can
bring back I think you know people like
Vanessa someone like Derrick I think you
could see Rachel one more time
and she could even win again if they
asked me to come back for an all-star
season I would most definitely come back
yeah I come back in a heartbeat
I go in there right now yes it was in
the same shirt okay all right
all those guys were back in Big Brother
world to shoot the revenger in a
ventures style movie trailer that will
debut on Sunday night's episode of Big
Brother for the annual BB comics themed
competition so do not miss it there's
also so much more from those interviews
up on ET online.com right now so click
on over there if you want to know which
- season 18 houseguests are now in love
speaking of time to talk all the music
I'm lovin right now because it's new
music Friday and there is so much to jam
out - starting with Kelly Clarkson who
is back to save music with her
first-ever R&B record here is in love so
soft
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that video is everything and so is
a new one for from dusk till dawn it's
like a little mini movie feature SIA
[Music]
all right and this song isn't new today
but I gotta plug this artist her name is
Liz oh and if you don't know her name
you should she was one of princes last
protegees and her music is all over
commercials TV and movies and she is the
next big thing her track water meet is
gonna be stuck in your head for the rest
of the day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right kids go on and update those a
weekend playlists and get off the
internet but first don't forget to
subscribe to ET here on YouTube it's
free and like this video if you liked me
you know what like it if you didn't like
me just like it buying